[Music]
welcome back y'all we've got Natalie
pman with
us our new incredible movie is called
May December it started streaming on
Netflix December 1st it's getting a lot
of Oscar buzz as happens with her I
assume in any film she does um and as
have many films that were released in
December so it is time for a game about
some of those movies not from this
December but from another December nor
my December may I have another December
[Music]
I love it I like it here to host is one
of Natalie's co-stars from No Strings
Attached you can see him at San
Francisco sketchfest he is hilarious
February 1st through the 4th is when
he'll be there please welcome friend of
the show guy
brandom what's up guys you look handsome
I like those color you look so exciting
this is
beautiful I know good to see you we're
elevated in New York it's very exciting
it's very sophistic thank you it's
lovely to see both of you allow me to
briefly explain the game for this game
the answers are all Oscar nominated
films that were released in the month of
December not this December but another
December okay okay is everybody clear
uhhuh Kelly Clarkson are you ready to
play this I'm ready to lose okay Natalie
pman are you ready to play this game yes
I am all right bring the intensity look
I love Oscar nominated but I'm also a
Turner and Hooch girl so like I I'm just
saying like I might not know all these
films you know the answer hit button and
shout it out but if you're wrong the
other person can steal Kelly Clarkson
you don't always win on knowing the
answer but you always win on aggression
okay yes yes yes um Kelly and Natalie
are each playing for one side of the
audience and there's a big prize on the
line so get
in okay
okay going down
Portman question one okay what musical
movie featured a Tango in a Cell Block
Kelly clks um Chicago it is
Chicago starring Catherine Z Jones Kelly
Clarks but gear question two okay what
movie found Merill as a Danish woman in
Kenya in love with oh my God CL of
Africa
Co so good I'm obsessed with her
specifically you asleep over there I I
kind of am all right get it together
Robert Redford also in that you're
representing for everyone no strings
attached okay question three what movie
was a winner of four Oscars four
definitely four and followed a pair of
brothers one who could count cards tell
how many toothpicks dropped from a box
Kelly that
is
what I am a shame oh my God oh my
God I honestly did not think I was going
to do well this Natalie you can do this
okay okay I want you to just say Center
yourself I want you to find your pride
and I want you to fight for that Pride
okay thank you thank all right question
four what film featured a young dancer
in the New York City Ballet slowly going
Kelly
Clarkson so sorry Black
Swan just so wait
wait just so you know I have lost game
to my own song so just so you know and
hathway just just annihilated me yeah on
since you've been gone yeah yeah I've
sng it once or twice all right you're a
great film Black Swan okay question
question five what movie followed two
Pals from South Boston one of whom was
wicked
smart Goodwill
Hunting love that Portman is bringing it
back one point Portman love that one
question six what what film was about a
sports agent who quit his job oh n
Portman Terry
MC Jerry Maguire she can have it she she
did it she did it that's
condescending she can have it I'm
already I didn't know if she was going
to get it all right thank you all right
she knew what it
was what movie found actor Russell Crow
riding on Windows Kelly CLK
look it's because I use it as a joke a A
Beautiful Mind yeah yeah
call really good Callie I would love to
tell you I feel bad for creaming you but
it feels good I'm really happy it feels
good for me too no but it still anyone's
game okay cuz the last one is always
worth a th point this last question is
worth a th000 points
fine okay hands on buzzers let's take
this seriously okay what film found two
Cowboys played by Jake and Heath n pman
broke Back Mountain ladies and
gentlemen your winner and Champion
Natalie Porton well done well done
congratulations you so sad for me all
right everybody s lab is an awardwinning
and personalizable candle that was one
of the hottest candles of the holiday
season if you know you know and I know
that you're all getting a $300 Cent lab
gift card you're welcome
a big thank you to guy Brandon for
hosting and Natalie BR for whooping my
behind and in San Francisco February
first and before if you got to check him
out you can see him with the San
Francisco sketchfest he's hilarious
catch guy and be sure to watch May
December on
[Music]
[Applause]
Netflix thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home